Speaker 1: We've talked a lot about the I
guess I would call it the need to create fake
scandals and crises kind of out of thin air
in these early months of the Joe Biden administration.
And part of that is necessitated by the fact
that while Joe Biden hasn't done everything
I wish he would, he had done and he hasn't
done everything perfectly and et cetera, et
cetera, all the normal disclaimers, he's had
nothing even close to a major scandal.
And for a while and we'll get to this in the
in the voicemail segment for a while, the
focus was on the so-called crisis at the border,
which was not a crisis under Donald Trump,
according to these very same people, even
though nothing really materially changed from
Trump to Biden, I wouldn't say they've moved
on from that.
But now the slightly more conspiratorial enclaves
of the right are going into why won't Joe
Biden let us investigate whether covid was
man made?
That's the gist of this.
And Fox News reporter Peter Doocy has gone
from asking different faux gotcha questions
from one press briefing to the next to just
repeating the exact same conspiratorial faux
gotcha questions day after day.
So check this out.
Monday, Tuesday, two press briefings, exact
same question back to back Monday is the first
one.
Peter Doocy asked Joe Biden's White House
press secretary, Jen Psaki, about an investigation
into whether covid-19 was man made.
Now, remember, I have no problem investigating
that.
Dr. Fauci said he has no problem investigating
it.
It's just that right now there's no evidence
that covid was manmade.
But do the investigation do everything you
need to in terms of covid-19.
So this is Monday.
Here is Peter Doocy asking, shouldn't we be
investigating this investigation?
Speaker 3: But with five hundred eighty nine
thousand nine hundred twenty dead Americans?
At what point does President Biden say, we
don't want to wait for the WHL, we don't know
what they're doing?
This needs to be an American led effort to
get to the bottom of what happened.
Speaker 4: Well, first of all, we need access
to the underlying data and information in
order to have that investigation.
Speaker 3: And but he talks all the time about
how he's known President Xi for a long time.
So why can't he just
Speaker 4: and and we need them for that information.
I think you're misunderstanding how this process
actually works.
An international investigation led by the
World Health Organization is something that
we've actually been pressing for for several
months in coordination with a range of partners
around the world.
We need that data.
We need that information from the Chinese
government.
What we can't do and what I would caution
anyone doing is leaping ahead of an actual
international process.
We don't have enough data and information
to jump to a conclusion at this point in time.
Speaker 3: So is there any amount of casualties
from covid in this country that would make
you want to not wait for an international
effort and just do it as well?
Speaker 4: I have to say, I think the family
members of the loved ones whose lives have
been lost and deserve accurate information
data, not the jumping to a conclusion without
having the information necessary to conclude
what the origins are.
What we do share everyone in this country
as a desire to know how this started, where
it started, and prevent it from ever happening
again.
That's something we all share.
Go ahead.
Speaker 1: OK, so that was Monday and Jen
Psaki says, yeah, do the probe, do it.
Let's find out.
Peter Doocy wants to frame it in so many of
these right wingers, you know, when they seize
on a kernel of something, then they just try
to blow it up into, I don't know, popcorn.
He wants to frame it as at what point would
covid be serious enough for Joe Biden to want
to investigate the origins of the virus?
And that's, of course, not the issue.
It's already serious enough.
It was Trump and Republicans who downplayed
the seriousness all along.
Nobody's trying to block an investigation
into the origins.
It's just without evidence right now.
The assertion that covid was likely or probably
manmade is an assertion without evidence.
And so we can't do that at this point in time.
It doesn't seem that he gets it.
So cut to the next day, yesterday, Tuesday.
Peter Doocy with the same thing again.
And Jen Psaki actually points out, Peter,
didn't we do this yesterday?
All right.
I guess we're doing it again.
Speaker 3: Does President Biden think he's
serious?
We hear more about now that covid-19 may have
been man made an escape from a lab in China
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based on
what he has heard and been briefed on, does
he think that's possible?
Speaker 4: Well, we went through this journey
together yesterday, so let's do it again.
So the president believes there needs to be
an independent investigation, one that's run
by the international community.
It's an international pandemic that has killed
hundreds of thousands of people around the
world.
He believes the Chinese need to do more to
put forward data to be.
More transparent and in the second phase of
this effort, he's certainly hopeful that will
be the case and he believes that every theory
should be explored through that process, but
that we shouldn't jump to conclusions before
that data and that information is made available.
Speaker 1: This is straight up kowtowing to
the Fox News audience.
The Fox News audience loves conspiracies.
They love the idea that Democrats aren't telling
them the truth.
And by Democrats, they also mean, apparently,
the public health community.
Now, it's also funny to watch the other reporters
try to keep straight faces.
When Peter Doocy is doing this, it's hard
to imagine anybody taking him seriously in
that press briefing room, but they do a good
job at pretending anyway.
Later, just the cherry on top.
Peter Doocy also framing a question about
a rise in crime under Joe Biden.
Of course, the rise in crime started last
summer under Trump, much of it crimes of economic
circumstance as a result of the pandemic.
And good job, Jen Psaki actually points it
out
Speaker 3: on the rise in violent crime compared
to this time last year.
Homicides 113 percent, Minneapolis up 38 percent.
In Philly, up 22 percent in Chicago.
Just to clarify, the White House's position
on this is that that is mostly because of
guns.
Speaker 4: Well, first, I'm not sure what
data you're looking at, but I think what we
can most data that is out there shows that
there's actually been a rise in crime over
the course of the last year since the start
of the pandemic, which actually predates President
Biden taking office.
To be totally clear right now.
You're right.
You're right, Peter.
And that's why we are focused.
Well, we're focused on solutions here, and
that's why we proposed putting a fight.
We put five billion dollars in the American
jobs plan.
Speaker 1: OK, so she gets into reading the
statistics, which is fine, but just desperate
to create chaos and controversy.
And it feels sort of wasted because there
really are good questions that Peter Doocy
could be asking if he wants to be tough on
the press briefing, the press secretary and
the process of press briefing and taking it
seriously.
But instead, it's just this drivel time and
time again.
Now, I will say one thing about Jen Psaki
is handling of this.
Her handling of it is generally good.
And sometimes you see, like, she was better
prepared for that.
When you get the same questions every day,
you get multiple attempts.
She was better prepared for the covid Origins
question on Tuesday than she was on Monday.
But she has to be careful because part of
asking the same question day in and day out
could maybe be to create an inconsistency
where she says one thing one day and another
thing the next, materially different things,
or maybe even a slip up of some kind, which
Peter Doocy and then Fox News and the whole
right wing media apparatus can focus in on
and seize on and make like a 24 hour story
out of it or even a bigger scandal or pseudo
scandal.
So clearly, she's tired of it.
Clearly, so are we.
But she actually does need to stay on point
every time and take the fully answer the question
every time that he asked these questions,
even if it's the same question every day because
they're just looking for an inconsistency
from her.
Jen Psaki, apparently the sort of kindergarten
teacher that's needed in the press briefing
room at this point in time.
Now, let me go briefly back to the lab leak
or the manmade theory of covid.
I don't know anyone who wouldn't want to know
if covid were manmade.
I would want to know.
There's no question about it.
The other scenario is if covid were naturally
occurring, but then leaked from a lab in which
it was being studied, I would want to know.
I just want the truth.
But before we have evidence, it's not responsible
to say it's probably manmade and it's not
responsible to say that that possibility is
being covered up.
And that's what the focus is right now.
Either the left doesn't want to talk about
it.
You should see Don Jr.'s recent tweets about
this or there's an actual cover up of the
fact that this was probably likely realistically
a manmade virus.
There's just no evidence of that study.
The origins, Dr. Fauci said it.
I've said it all along.
Study the origins.
Let's not make assertions for which we do
not
have evidence.